la parole est à Monsieur Loïc et Hervé
rapporteur de la commission des lois
pour 10 minutes
sur un porteur
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur l'auteur de la
proposition de loi madame la conciliaire
donc cher françois-secatel mes chers
collègues on pourrait problématiser
cette proposition de loi autour de la
question de savoir si la défense contre
l'incendie est un sujet suffisamment
grave pour qu'il ne soit confié qu'à
ceux qui ont la maîtrise de l'art et
finalement cette réflexion que nous
allons conduire cet après-midi tourne
autour de cette seule question cette
proposition de loi examiner cet
après-midi entendre répondre à un
problème lancinant que les communes
notamment rurales ne connaissent que
trop bien l'exercice particulièrement
complexe de leur mission en matière de
défense extérieure contre l'incendie
les difficultés en la matière sont
connues de longue date et elles sont
connues de nous tous
la consultation du répertoire des
questions écrites de nos collègues
députés comme de nos collègues sénateurs
corrobores le sentiment qu'un État
historiquement velléitaire en la matière
des sollicitations restées lettres
mortes en promesse de réforme non tenue
le sujet a trop longtemps constitué un
irritant pour les mères de de des zones
rurales
si aujourd'hui la passivité l'inertie de
l'État en la matière ne semble plus de
mise nous le devons tout
particulièrement notre collègue Hervé
Morin très mobilisé et de manière
constante pour la défense des intérêts
des communes rurales sur ce sujet coteur
d'un rapport en 2021 avec notre collègue
Franck Montauger et auteur d'une
proposition de loi qui nous revient
d'examiner cet après-midi
le cadre juridique applicable à ses
missions avaient pourtant été largement
revisité par la loi varsmann en 2011
pour mémoire ce cadre prévoit une
hiérarchie des normes entre plusieurs
documents dont le règlement
départemental de défense extérieure
contre l'incendie le RD d ECI pardon
chers collègues il y aura des acronymes
cet après-midi et ce règlement
départemental en constitue le nœud ces
règlements départementaux établis en
concertation avec les mers et arrêté par
le préfet de département après avis du
conseil d'administration du 10 doivent
tenir compte d'un référentiel national
le
rndeci et s'impose aux communes dont les
arrêtées et éventuelles schéma en
matière de deci doivent être conformes
au règlement départemental
outre le délai jugé excessif de mise en
application de cette réforme les
difficultés des communes n'ont pas
trouvé de solutions définitives dans
cette réforme et comme la relevée de
Hervé Morin et comme l'on relever Hervé
Moret et Franck motoger dans leur
rapport de 2021 c'est des difficultés
sont de 4 ordres premièrement la
concertation est jugée aller disons le
mot inégal
la concentration à l'égard des élus dans
l'élaboration des règlements
départementaux deuxième
réflexion la couverture du risque est
parfois qualifiée de défaillante
l'adéquation entre les prescriptions du
règlement départemental et les risques
réelles les premières n'étant toujours
pas proportionnés au second en raison de
l'évaluation insuffisante et de la
complexité des règles surtout du défaut
d'adaptation de celle-ci aux
spécificités des territoires notamment
en milieu rural combien parmi nous
entendu parler de la tristement célèbre
règle des 200 ou 400 mètres on parle ici
de longueur de tuyaux on approche des
élections sénatoriales
au mois de septembre mais ce sujet a
occupé les élections sénatoriales de
2020 on est trois ans plus tard et on
continue d'avancer sur ce sujet
quatrième réflexion le coût financier à
la fois budgétaire et en termes de
développement économique notamment
lorsqu'une autorisation d'urbanisme ne
peut être accordée en raison du défaut
de couverture du risque incendie
l'examen en commission de la présente
proposition de loi a permis de
retravailler le dispositif initialement
inventé par notre collègue Hervé Moret
afin de le simplifier et de renforcer la
portée du dispositif finalement on est
allé au bout de la réflexion d'Hervé
Moret en faisant du RDD aussi un volet à
part entière du Dacre
en effet les personnes que j'ai
auditionnées ont généralement convenu de
l'incongruité que pouvait constituer la
coexistence du schéma départemental
d'analyse et de couverture des risques
le Zac avec ce règlement départemental
de défense etc contre l'incendie
de l'Assemblée des départements de
France à la Fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers de France en passant
par des échanges avec le directeur
général de la Sécurité civile et de la
gestion des crises je préfère un intérêt
lui-même personne n'était vraiment en
mesure d'expliquer l'intérêt de
l'existence de deux documents distincts
parfois même madame la ministre n'ont
pas seulement la coexistence mais
l'herméticité qui pouvait exister entre
les deux et certains travaux sénatoriaux
ont démontré quelque chose qui
paraissait complètement incongrue je
reprends ce terme tout porte ainsi à
croire que la défense extérieure contre
l'incendie
constitue le parent pauvre de
l'organisation des moyens de lutte
contre l'incendie il y a donc été fait
le choix d'en faire un document annexe
distinct et sans articulations avec le
document stratégique que constitue le
stack or il me semble que la prise en
compte des moyens et des difficultés
rencontrées par les communes en matière
de défense extérieur contre l'incendie
doit justement constituer un élément de
la stratégie on verra tout à l'heure
dans les amendements mais à fortiori
avec les changements climatiques que
nous connaissons et à Forterie avec ses
incendies importants que nous
connaissons dans beaucoup de
départements même dans des départements
qui n'étaient pas exposés jusqu'à là la
détermination et la location des moyens
ne saurait faire l'économie d'une
analyse des forces et faiblesses de la
défense contre l'incendie dans un
département le Dax doit prévoir des
adaptations de ces prescriptions en
fonction des forces et des faiblesses en
fonction des réalités du terrain ainsi
ce volet défense extérieur contre
l'incendie du Dacre constituerait ainsi
à porter réglement départemental et sans
qu'il soit besoin de le préciser dans la
loi les arrêter communaux et
intercommunaux en matière de défense
extérieure contre l'incendie qui devrait
être conforme à ce nouveau volet du
schéma départemental
cette mesure constituera également une
simplification des documents organisant
les services d'incendie de secours qui
n'ont jamais fait l'objet d'une réforme
globale portant vision d'ensemble et
stratégique de ses compétences la
procédure d'adoption du volet spécifique
de la défense extérieure contre
l'incendie au sein du DAX s'inspire très
largement de celle aujourd'hui
applicables pour les laboration du
règlement des départements elle concerne
néanmoins deux apports du dispositif
initial le projet de documents ferait
l'objet d'une concertation élargie le
Conseil départemental et les conseils
municipaux ou organes délibérant des
EPCI conséquents compétents pardon étant
désormais consulté pour avis et d'une
évaluation préalable du service public
de la défense extérieure contre
l'incendie conformément au souhaits de
l'auteur de la proposition de loi Hervé
Moret le principe d'une révision
concomitante du Zac et de son volet
relatif à la défense secteur contre
l'incendie serait également conservé
ce dispositif a été harmonieusement
complété par un amendement
de notre collègue Hervé Moret que nous
avons repris en commission lors de son
examen tendant à créer une commission
départementale de suivi de la défense
extérieure contre l'incendie constitué
d'élus elle aurait pour mission d'une
part de procédés à l'évaluation
régulière de l'état de la couverture des
risques au regard des points d'eau situé
sur le territoire dont elle ferait état
dans un rapport annuel et d'autre part
de formuler toutes proposition
d'évolution qu'elle jugerait pertinente
cette piste d'évolution évoquée par la
direction générale dans un rapport de
juin 2022 me paraît consensuel et
permettrait aux élus de disposer d'un
espace et de d'écoute et de dialogue
avec le service départemental d'incendie
et ce que nous avons tellement
été attentif à cette proposition d'Hervé
Moret que nous avons même prévu une
incompatibilité entre les élus siégeants
dans la commission
de défense contre l'incendie et ceux qui
siègent au sein comme conseil
d'administration du 10 pour bien qu'on
ait un dialogue éclairé entre d'un côté
les maires de communes nous avons
rurales et d'un autre côté ceux qui dans
le département sont en charge de la
lutte contre l'incendie au sein du
conseil d'administration des services
d'incendie et de secours nous avons
enfin prévu que le rapport annuel de
cette Commission puisse faire fonction
sur décision du Conseil administration
du 10 d'évaluation préalable du service
public de la défense extérieur contre
l'incendie l'année précédant la révision
du Dacre cette modification me paraît
naturel à renforcer la place de cette
commission qui pourrait se voir
attribuer un rôle majeur dans
l'élaboration du volley défense
extérieur contre l'incendie du Dacre
elle constitue ainsi une mesure de
simplification des évaluations des
évaluations aux objectifs similaires
n'ayant passé nécessairement vocation à
être multipliées le texte qui vous est
proposé mes chers collègues cet
après-midi et donc équilibré pragmatique
et consensuel pour finir je tiens à
saisir l'opportunité qui met donner
aujourd'hui de remercier nos collègues
sénateurs qui sur tous les bancs ont
permis de cheminer ensemble vers une
amélioration significative de la vie des
communes rurales en matière de défense
extérieure contre l'incendie je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Madame